vous connaissez cette jeune femme mado
robin c'est une figure emblématique 10h
sur creuse une cantatrice avec la voile
la plus aiguë du monde jamais égalée
encore aujourd'hui si vous voulez en
savoir un petit peu plus sur elle on va
aller dans le musée qui lui est consacré
suivez moi afin d'être une cantatrice de
renom madeleine marie robin dit mado est
une enfant du pays uni 0 âge né en 1918
au talent incontestable
elle a vécu toute son enfance à yzeure
et ton père était négociant têtes de
bétail donc c'est une famille assez
aisée et les filles à effet de serre est
pratiqué beaucoup le chant la musique et
en fait on s'est très vite aperçu à
l'époque qu'elle avait une voix assez
phénoménal son père lui fait passer des
auditions à paris emma 2 séduit la
capitale on y va de ses lances elle
enchaîne opérettes et opéra et se fait
un nom parmi les plus grandes
cantatrices de l'époque elle est très
célèbre et elle voyage un peu partout
dans le monde aux états unis et surtout
en urss
à l'époque c'était l'urss qu'on peut
être 15 république
je dis ça parce qu'en fait elle a été
chantée en géorgie actuelle en arménie
en intervalles gens à bas coûts ce qui
était assez rare pour l'époque parce que
j'étais en pleine guerre froide
elle a même réussi à y aller être invité
par les autorités soviétiques et elle
avait beaucoup de conseils
rares sont les cantatrices autant
demander à l'international et la raison
du succès le mât de robin tient en une
note sont peut être contre euro
[Musique]
elle chantait très très haut en contre
contrerait est en fait c'est la voie la
plus haute et la plus aiguë du monde et
qui chante juste dit mieux oui c'est
mieux mais par rapport aux autres
cantatrice beaucoup cherchent à la
comparer à la callas mais c'est pas loin
de registre vocal
par exemple ma de roman aurait eu du mal
à chanter du wagner qu'un registre
beaucoup plus bas parmi les rôles
interprétés par mado robin il y en a un
dans lequel alex et les lacs mai
[Musique]
c'est son rôle préféré c'est un opéra
qui a été écrit par léo delibes s et il
est très peu joué parce qu'en fait il
peut monter très haut pour pouvoir le
jouer en gros beaucoup disent que
l'atmea est écrit pour moi du robin et
maghrébins mais pour chanter la cne
soixante ans après sa mère mado robin
continue de vivre à travers ce musée
visité par des fans et des touristes
curieux charmé par cette voix qui a
résonné sur les plus grandes scènes
d'opéra
[Musique]
sylvie on vient de découvrir le musée
mado robin là on arrive dans le musée
minerve ces voies du seigneur
alors qu'est ce que c'est ce musée on
est un type s de grande chapelle en bois
on voit des grosses pierres racontez moi
qu'est ce que c'est ce sont des blocs
donc qui font partie d'un pilier votifs
dédié à jupiter et ses blocs ont été
découverts lors de la on va dire
reconstruction de l'église puisque
l'église a été reconstruite un petit peu
avant le vingtième siècle fin du 19e et
à ce moment là ils ont découvert tous
ces blocs
c'était un très grand pilier qu'ils
avaient mesuré environ 9 mètres donc
évidemment toutes les pierres ne sont
pas là mais les on a récupéré quelques
années pour sylvie septembre vous êtes
élue à la commune 10 heures sur creuse
on voit qu'il ya deux musées qui sont
côte à côte sur la même place c'est une
chance il est important de conserver la
mémoire ou c'est bien des pierres que
des personnes comme ma de revin donc la
commune a misé un peu là-dessus
effectivement on voit le musée mado
roman par exemple ça fait presque douze
ans qu'il est là il se fait quand même
sa place on a des grands musées à côté
on cerne mal grand pressigny on a des
choses pas très loin vous êtes quand
même toujours là en 2021
on est toujours là effectivement on vous
on aimerait le faire vivre un peu plus
et on est en recherche effectivement de
moyens de le faire vivre plus mais
peut-être qu'on ne parviendra pas ce
qu'on ayant cet héritage là aussi où il
ya des personnes motivées j'imagine
qu'ils qui travaille beaucoup sur ça des
personnes et c'est effectivement de
travailler là dessus ce n'est pas
forcément facile de faire revenir les
gens une fois qu'ils ont visité une
première fois mais donc on essaie de
trouver deux mètres de l'intérêt dans ce
musée pour que les personnes puissent
revenir on est partant de cosider
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter dans
ces deux musées 10 heures on aimerait
bien que les gens puissent revenir
effectivement pour le visiter et à cette
occasion d'ailleurs il est prévu de
faire un escape game qui cumule les deux
musées donc on espère que cette occasion
les gens reviendront et et encore plus
après avoir le temps de plus pendant les
vacances ça voilà vous savez désormais
où il faut venir pour visiter
d'optimiser à ce sympathique c'est ici à
yzeures sur creuse dans le sud du
département de l'indre et loire